real quick go check out jayatel the UK's
most exciting electronic music duo their
newest release connected is available
wherever you get music it's energetic
melodic blast of Electronica ingeniously
infused with acoustic instruments and
they support the David Pacman show check
them out using the link below
so the more we learn about Ron
desantis's Martha's Vineyard immigrant
stunt the more we realize it was
certainly immoral it was certainly
unethical it was certainly a waste of
Florida taxpayer money to send
immigrants that were in Texas to an
island off the coast of Massachusetts
those things we all know we know that it
was dishonest because we have now
learned that the immigrants were indeed
enticed with false promises of all sorts
of goodies at the end of the rainbow for
lack of a better term but now there's a
new question and as often is the case
with the very people who claim that they
are all about law enforcement and due
process and doing everything correctly
in Law and Order or Line Auto as Donald
Trump has said before it may not have
been legal either and there is a very
very good article in NPR about this on
npr.org by Valerie Crowder and I'm going
to tell you some of the key points here
that are now in question about whether
this was Lee legal or could it have been
illegal human trafficking so the first
aspect to this is that Ron DeSantis
described the flights on which the
immigrants were taken to Martha's
Vineyard as voluntary when he was
speaking at a press conference on Friday
it appears that that was a lie
immigration law experts say that
actually what happened was the
trafficking of migrants when you lie to
people to induce them to come somewhere
to the U.S or whatever in order for
something that is not true you are
participating in what is functionally
speaking the same type of trafficking
where young girls are tricked into going
wherever uh with the promises of
whatever it is they're promised and then
they're actually forced into
prostitution as an example the dynamic
is exactly the same and we've now
learned that these immigrants were told
you're going to be flown to Boston they
weren't they were flown to Martha's
Vineyard you'll get expedited work
papers which was not actually what was
waiting for them in Martha's Vineyard
and instead what happened was churches
and shelters and Aid groups as NPR
rights did the best to accommodate them
on an island with an extraordinarily low
population and very limited resources
now then we heard from a
tallahassee-based immigration attorney
Elizabeth Ricci also quoted in this NPR
article who says there is a good faith
argument to be made
that when you lure migrants onto planes
with false promises of jobs you are
making them victims of fraudulent human
trafficking
think of that that is what the governor
of Florida has potentially engaged in
here they were told oh you might uh
you're going to get this you're going to
get that now here's the unbelievable
part
if indeed these individuals are
determined to have been the victims of
Fraud and human trafficking they could
automatically qualify for visas here in
the United States what Ron DeSantis may
have illegally done could we don't know
yet actually genuinely expedite these
individuals to legal status here in the
United States Richie explained quote an
enticement like that regardless of
whether you sign a waiver is fraud and
that's part of the definition of human
trafficking I think that everybody on
those planes has a case to legalize as a
direct result of being transported by
the governor Republicans will do illegal
things
and if they get arrested or prosecuted
they will claim they are merely
political prisoners that they're being
treated unfairly this is what happened
after the January 6 riots the January
6th rioters and there were hundreds of
them I think the numbers up to seven or
eight hundred although it may even be
over a thousand they were
um uh acting criminally
and then once the law caught up with
them uh these the claims started to be
made of well they're they're not being
given the right food in jail they're
being held unfairly in jail pre-trial
detention is unfair these are victims of
politics they're being punished because
of their opinion about an election this
is the move so without a doubt if the
law starts to catch up to DeSantis and
whoever else for this absurd stunt
mark my words and you know this I don't
have to convince you of this they will
claim they are actually the victims the
people who did this who were just trying
to prove a point now one other thing
there are right Wingers who think
they're being really slick by saying
something like the following and there's
versions of this floating around you
know
all you Northern liberals talk about
Texas and Florida and Arizona should
just accept hundreds of thousands of
migrants and it's very easy to say from
Vermont or from Massachusetts or
whatever but as soon as 50 people get to
Martha's Vineyard they are immediately
deported out
multiple things going on here first of
all it's not a deportation when you're
just flown from one state to another
that's number one number two the intent
of these immigrants was not to be in
Martha's Vineyard Martha's Vineyard is
Tiny there's very few jobs it's a very
small economy and it's a very seasonal
economy because of Tourism and we're
heading into fall and then winter which
is low season in Martha's Vineyard
there's not the real opportunity
for any jobs there there's
extraordinarily limited housing Etc so
there's really not the hypocrisy that
the right wants to point out furthermore
they were lied to
in so getting to Martha's Vineyard and
as I mentioned it was not their intent
so this this hypocrisy that the right is
trying to expose in talking about the
Martha's Vineyard thing it's a joke and
we shouldn't allow them to turn that
around because it just doesn't make any
sense whatsoever if you want to see some
real cringe on this entire Martha's
Vineyard and just generally flying
immigrants bussing immigrants around
stun I have video for you today a Fox
News sending listen I don't know who
speaks Spanish at Fox News like I don't
know who they have that speaks Spanish
but one guy that multiple times have
been has been sent to speak Spanish to
migrants is a reporter named Griff
Jenkins that's not the guy on the screen
right now this is Steve Ducey who's
going to cut to Griff Jenkins it's hard
to think of a more cringy video
throughout the last couple weeks of this
immigrant Martha's Vineyard Washington
DC busing airplane Fiasco then this
video
uh Venezuelan migrants mostly Venezuelan
migrants not all were quote interviewed
by Griff Jenkins and he can barely speak
Spanish he has no idea what they're
saying the migrants can barely
understand his Spanish it almost seems
like a parody take a look at this
from our Southern border have just
arrived outside vice president Kamala
Harris's Residence at the Naval
Observatory in Washington D.C by the way
this is also part of the stunt right
send a bus of migrants right to where
Kamala Harris lives it does this doesn't
help anyone this this is just a stun
Griff Jenkins is live on the scene to
tell us more Griff is that Massachusetts
Avenue that I'm looking at right there
yeah good morning Steve amazing Brian
this bus just arrived moments ago I
talked to some of the folks apparently
this bus has come from Del Rio Texas
that's right A Gentleman on the bus told
me and he's part of me they don't the
Harris
so that way if you if you missed what
that was that was the Don Davis de Don
Davis
and even if you speak Spanish it's like
what is he saying what he's trying to
ask is
where are you from that's the question
de Don Davis
sounds more like a Kanye album
English
okay so he asked she says she's from
Venezuela asks if she speaks English she
says no Tina no la la la la la president
uh Harris
DK
Frontera
serado okay so when he says there
Frontera serado what he means is
the border is closed
um Kamala Harris said the border is
closed now
I don't know whether it's reasonable to
think that Venezuelan migrants who have
been on a bus for a whole bunch of time
and coming through Mexico and all these
things that they would necessarily be up
on the latest declarations from Kamala
Harris so the entire thing is bad faith
but here's the answer
but Frontera is Serato or Alberto
so he asked is the Border open or closed
and she says it's open and this is
supposed to be some kind of gotcha
moment she's saying Steve I asked her
vice president Harris says that the
border is closed she says it's open as
we see these migrants coming across now
we're not sure how many there are we do
know that according to Texas governor
Abbott's office there have been about 7
900 pardon me do you speak English
Venezuela okay so another individual
correctly identifying the Don Davis as
where are you from and says he's from
Venezuela
everybody from todos Venezuela
um
so Griff asks is everybody on the bus
from Venezuela and the guy says yeah
mostly you know it's a really difficult
situation in Venezuela right now much
[Music]
[Music]
so what this gentleman is explaining and
Griff Jenkins has absolutely no idea
what's being said and it actually this
would be the most interesting thing to
translate is yes you know it's been a
really difficult trip we've been
traveling for days they kind of screwed
us in Mexico and we just we want to be
here we want to do things we want to
work I I believe he said this would
actually be relevant to translate but of
course they're not actually set up for
that
okay thank you yeah buenos your day so
I'm not gonna be able to translate all
that and I wouldn't even try because it
wouldn't look good on live TV but yeah
he has no idea what the guy said as you
can see they're coming across here all
of these migrants it appears to be at
least 20 or so at this point we have two
buses so what I was saying was we know
from Governor Abbott's office there have
been about 7 900 migrants on over 190
buses coming to DC more than 2200 on
more than 40 buses to New York and of
course about five buses to Chicago with
a little over 300 migrants let's see if
we can get one more interview in Griff
because they're just so good I don't
know the heirs the donde heires yes
so he says I don't understand English
which is really funny because Griff
appears to be tried to speak Spanish and
this guy's like I don't sorry I don't
speak English I'm in English no no no
okay
now he's talking to a kid
now he starts talking to a kid at which
point I'm gonna cut the interview
um it seems like a parody
it is important to mention if all these
folks are really coming over it kind of
seems to prove Trump didn't really build
the wall right I mean he claims he built
it and yet of course the wall could be
defeated with a hundred dollars in
supplies from a Home Depot as we learn
so no great deterrent if it were built
but it wasn't but Trump claims it was
and yet these folks are still here so
just another one of these pathetic
displays get an actual Spanish-speaking
reporter who can translate you know the
the thing about it is
if you're going to try to communicate in
Spanish
and you're going to struggle that's okay
as long as then you have the ability to
understand and explain what these folks
are saying because the guy there who
told the story of how they came to be in
the U.S traveling for days Mexican
immigration all these different things
if you don't speak Spanish you have no
clue what the guy said and Griff Jenkins
just laughs it off by saying I'm not
going to try to translate all that these
people are pathetic and it's disgusting
let me know what you think find me on
Twitter at dpacman we're going to take a
quick break and be right back
one of our sponsors today is Jay atal
jayital is a stellar melodic dance music
duo in one of the UK's most exciting
electronic acts Jay atal have made their
name through legendary live shows that
incorporate drums Guitar Electronics
taking them on tours across Europe
they've appeared on BBC their newest
release called connected will knock you
off your feet written and recorded
entirely remotely during covid my
favorite track from the album is the one
you're hearing right now called it's
coming round again
foreign
probably because I'm a drummer but I
Love acoustic drums accompanied by a bed
of electronic layers and the track
really gets the drums going in all of
their music even something as simple as
the synth bass sounds like it was
carefully adjusted for hours to hit your
ear just the right way these guys will
take you on a journey and Jay ital are
big fans of the David Pacman show if you
like unusual but deeply gratifying
Electronica check out Jay atal on their
new release connected wherever you
stream or buy music they're on YouTube
and social media you can book them for a
show and you can find them using the
link below
[Music]
foreign the David pakman show is nothing
but a community supported program you
can sign up at joinpakman.com and get
instant access to the award-winning
bonus show
it's all Awards we give I'm glad to
admit that but a number of Milestone
Awards now racking up for that bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com radical
and very repugnant Republican uh
repugnant Republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green appears to have
kicked a gun safety accident activist
two times and it's on video
um this is these are the people who say
we're against violence I guess I mean I
don't know it seems like they're against
it only in certain cases a congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green denies she kicked
an 18 year old political activist in an
incident caught on video in which it's
pretty damn clear that that's exactly
what she did Marjorie Taylor green was
walking uh behind gun rights activist
Mariana pakora Mariana pakora is holding
a phone recording and not once but twice
in this video
I see Marjorie Taylor green deliberately
looking down and appearing to kick
Mariana pakora this is an elected member
of Congress yes elected by lunatics but
that is the United States of America
lunatics are allowed to elect whoever
they want and lunatics are allowed to
run and sometimes they elect each other
let's take a look at this video see what
you make of it and again if you're just
listening today I'll describe it
okay so there's the first kick Marjorie
Taylor green kind of speeding up and you
can tell that she just she steps on her
or kicks her and then Mariana kind of
moves to her right and then it happens
again
[Music]
a second kick and of course it's all
under the guise of oh you're walking
right in front of me and so closely and
all of these different things oh it's
all an accident
you're blocking the congresswoman that's
why she kicked you twice
yeah so there's Marjorie Taylor green
and remember she is
um in favor of due process and she's in
favor of the rule of law uh she's for
Law and Order she's against violence and
yet you see that she very clearly kind
of speeds up in order to kick her on the
back of the leg
and kicks her two or three times this
woman is truly the lowest of the low it
looks like assault to me I hope Mariana
picara uh presses charges and
um initially there was a a camera angle
that made it seem potentially accidental
there really seems to be no question
here that it's intentional it's just a
question of can you actually demonstrate
that or show it for sure but think about
how far you know it's we've talked about
their allegations are actually
confessions oh the Democrats are going
to use voter fraud and try to steal an
election they don't win
to what Republicans did right and we
have dozens of such examples when here
it comes to this issue of we're against
violence but you should be able to talk
about anything you want remember they
love saying that on Twitter you should
be able to talk about whatever you want
and there should never you don't we
don't use physical
uh accosting or violence or we don't do
that is everybody should be allowed to
talk and say whatever they want free
from violence well here is a public
Street where an activist goes to
Marjorie Taylor green and asks a
question about the Second Amendment
which is what they claim we should all
be able to do I mean it's America after
all and Marjorie Taylor green kicks this
woman at least twice if not three times
their principles don't matter once they
are inconvenient and questions about the
Second Amendment
in these formats are inconvenient to
these Republicans and so this is the
outcome it's truly despicable I hope
charges are filed we're continuing our
coverage of some of the most important
and consequential races in 2022 one such
race is the Georgia Senate election this
is the race in which Democrat Rafael
Warnock is the incumbent and on the
other side very disturbingly Herschel
Walker former NFL football player is the
Republican nominee there is a new series
of videos of Herschel Walker at some
kind of event and in this event you know
we've heard Herschel Walker be
completely incoherent about the economy
we've heard Herschel Walker be
completely incoherent about uh gun
violence we've heard Herschel Walker be
completely incoherent about social media
here he delves into issues of race
relations and the Constitution and what
he refers to as the 14th Amendment now
that is that's not my pronunciation I
want to be very clear but this is
another one of these examples where
Walker looks visibly confused by the
things coming out of his mouth he
doesn't seem to know what he's saying
and certainly no one in the room has any
clue what this guy is saying and he is
even
even in the polls with Raphael Warnock
this is one of the most important races
not only is it important
because if Democrats do hold the Senate
it may be by only one seat and if this
race doesn't go the way of Raphael
Warnock it could be because of Herschel
Walker that Democrats lose control of
the Senate it's important for that
reason it's also important because this
guy is so unqualified to be a senator
that
it really puts in serious relief I guess
I would say you really feel the texture
of how absurd the modern Republican
party has become that they're willing to
vote for a guy like this so let's listen
to this first clip about the 14th
Amendment
whoa
I said probably read the Bible
forgiveness and I said if you read the
Constitution and the 14th Amendment do
you know our forefather was apologizing
for the whiteness because they said
every man be treated Fair
but what has happened we elected the
wrong people to office that didn't pick
up a ton up and run with it okay dude
do you know what he just said
if you read the Constitution
the 14th Amendment
you know our forefather was apologizing
for their whiteness because they say
every man be treated Fair
but what has happened we elected the
wrong people to office that didn't pick
up the Baton and run with it
I don't know what that means
about what was happening whether they're
trying to fix it yeah
and the woman to his left nodding she
seems to get it I don't know what he's
talking about guys I genuinely don't and
these are just the top scrambled is the
only way I can describe the talking
points
um here's another example of this stuff
and you know what what is true is what
has been pointed out by some of our
viewers he's doing like a red meat word
salad it's like a it's like a republican
red meat Bingo where even if it's
completely scrambled in terms of its
syntax
um there are individual words there that
are triggers to Republicans to get mad
we laugh but they're talking about a
green agenda they get mad at me because
I said I don't want any more trees I
don't I want police officers right so
this is like mixing two things green
agenda oh that's very bad very very bad
and I want police officers oh yeah yeah
we support the police I mean okay
not the law enforcement officers that
handled the search warrant at Trump's
house and not the Capitol Police that
were there on January 6th we don't
support them but as a general concept we
support police officers
[Applause]
eight is seven IRS agents
87
RS agents now it's just a scrambled
talking point you guys might remember
there's this talking point about
Joe Biden's hiring 87 000 new IRS agents
now the truth is 55 000 of them are over
the next period of time because there's
so many employees retiring from the IRS
it's just to replace them we'll go over
the details of those numbers Friday but
the talking point is 87 000 IRS agents
the talking point is a lie
and Herschel Walker calls the talking
point 87 agents they're laughing because
I say trees no I don't want trees I want
police officers yeah what I want to do
is I can tell you this
I can tell you this I happen to be doing
the Judah was telling you about the
theme weeks I was doing
he's doing a theme week I don't know if
it's infrastructure or whatever and so
what's the scariest thing about all of
this
the scariest thing about all of this is
that if you look at the real clear
politics average Georgia Senate Walker
versus Warnock you see that it is now a
tie
if you look at the last four polls it's
Walker plus one in the right-leaning
Trafalgar poll Walker plus two in an
Emerson poll Walker plus three in an
Insider Advantage poll and Warnock plus
six in a Quinnipiac pull now I will tell
you I believe the Quinnipiac poll is
probably the highest quality poll of the
four that's the one that has Warnock
winning
but this is really scary stuff the
people of Georgia May send a man who
can't explain his views on any issue to
be one of 100 members of the Senate if
you're listening today and you'd like to
take a look at those clips I just played
head on over to our Instagram at
davidpackman show and you can check out
the full horror of those clips
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
Donald Trump held a rally in Ohio on
Saturday night it was ostensibly for J.D
Vance who's the Republican Senate
candidate there running against Tim Ryan
this was the most cultish Trump rally I
have ever seen a new staple at the Trump
rallies is that when Donald Trump is
doing his kind of final build to his
make America great again make America
safe again they now play
I don't even know like like an esoteric
musical bed that almost seems fake it
almost seems like a parody this is the
one of the strangest moments I've ever
seen at any political rally ever
globally experts on Fascism and Cults
are pouring over this video like the
Zapruder film take a look at this
we are a nation that allowed Russia to
devastate a country Ukraine
killing hundreds of thousands of people
and it will only get worse and what you
can see there is the cult people holding
up a single finger now there's to it
there's a bunch of interpretations of
this one is there's this Q Anon thing
which is like uh I I forget exactly it's
like
wwg1 wga
and what the phrase means is where one
of us goes we will go together and so
the one that is being held could be the
one from that Q Anon thing another
interpretation is they're doing the Heil
Hitler but with a single finger to make
it less crazy looking I don't think that
that's what this is
it's insane but this is a very serious
cult it would never have happened with
me as your commander-in-chief
and for four long years it didn't happen
and China
Taiwan
ized its law enforcement against the
opposing political party like never ever
before
we've got a Federal Bureau of
Investigation that won't allow bad
election-changing facts to be presented
to the public
where Hunter Biden's laptop folks this
is the United States this is a former
president
was Russian disinformation when they
knew it wasn't
and a department of justice that refuses
to investigate egregious acts of voting
irregularities and fraud and we have a
president who is cognitively impaired
and in no condition to lead our country
which may end up
in World War III yeah somehow I don't
think so we're a nation that no longer
has a free press
has no fair press any longer fake news
is all you get and they are truly the
enemy of the people
we are a nation where free speech is no
longer allowed where crime is rampant
like never before where the economy has
been collapsing where more people died
of covet in 2021 than in 2020 we are a
nation that is allowing Iran to build a
massive nuclear weapon and China to use
the trillions of dollars it has taken
from all right let's pause it here
like nothing I have ever seen before
truly and completely fascistic these are
sort of like
dictatorial wet dreams I mean this this
would make Fidel Castro blush quite
frankly
um later on a lot of other of the
typical things also happen during the
speech later on Donald Trump seemed to
forget where he was like where he was
giving the speech and he referred to it
as this location are you McKinley you
know he's a great president he was the
king of tariffs that's why I like him
because he said that we don't want other
foreign powers coming in here and
stealing our wealth
he was hailed from right here he came in
from this right this location
that's the best he was such an important
place he was from it was from right this
here where we are now
um Donald Trump still completely
scrambled on Ulysses S Grant continuing
to first of all it's weird how much
Trump refers to Ulysses S Grant and it's
also weird that he keeps calling him
Ulysses
for their Beloved Country Ohio is the
state that gave us
American Heroes icons and legends with
names like Neil Armstrong Annie Oakley
and the great General and President
Ulysses S Grant but there is Ulysses uh
still I mean you would think someone
would come up to him with tears in their
eyes and say sir it's Ulysses uh Donald
Trump uh bemoaned the claims about a
urine tape involving Trump saying it was
really tough to explain that one to
Melania in the phony steel dossier it
was all phony how'd you like to be me
and go home and explain that one to my
wife
darling it wasn't true I swear it wasn't
remember that one with the hookers from
Russia
darling I'd like to explain this to you
it was all phony it was all a phony made
up yep it was all fake and then lastly
it wasn't all fun in games there was a
moment where the crowd in in Ohio
was so bored that they were in complete
silence and at one point in this clip if
you're watching you'll see the camera
cut to the crowd they are they almost
look like statues and 100 would have
never happened should have never
happened but
we gave now
80 billion dollars and Europe has given
six now Europe is a similar size when
all added up to the United States the
economy Europe if you add it all up and
they're in for a lot less money than us
and you know it's a sad thing because
they're in for less but they're affected
a lot more than we are yeah just an
electric environment there an electric
atmosphere so a deranged rally in Ohio
was supposedly in support of JD Vance at
one point during the thing Trump
actually made fun of JD Vance it's all
backwards it was all completely uh
people's brains are turning to
mayonnaise at these rallies is what it
seems like and of course the attendees
weren't much better let's look at that
next I have a we're going to look at a
couple of videos from attendees at the
Youngstown Ohio Trump rally over the
weekend this was the rally at which
Donald Trump was supposedly going to
support JD Vance although he at one
point made fun of JD Vance but that
doesn't really matter let's look at some
of the videos of people who went this
one is unbelievable
uh there is a woman who is thrilled that
Trump called out to her even though
Trump referred to her as this guy this
especially with everything that's going
on right now with Trump's transphobia
and the Resurgence of transphobia among
the rights something about this video
just cracks me up check this out what
about time
president talk to me beforehand or at
the end at the end I hollered I loved
him he stopped and he said I love you
too and then he thought he said this guy
says he loves me and I swear I'm a woman
oh it's it it all of these events are
completely Beyond parody I mean it's
it's unbelievable it's unbelievable and
it's funny because these folks love to
say
Democrats and the left you don't know
what a woman is you can't identify a
woman it's so obvious what's a woman
what's a man who's a woman who's a man
and then now it's all a big joke that
Trump thought this woman was a man I
guess some Republicans struggle with
that as well it seems and it sort of
puts into particular perspective these
absurd transphobic anecdotes that Donald
Trump now regularly tells at his rallies
another interview that took place with a
rally attendee was actually with a
January 6th defendant Mickey Larson
known as the Q Patriot I guess was
interviewed by Donald Trump's attorney
Christina Bob who is also an anchor on
right side broadcasting I mean every
detail is absurd take a listen to this
and I served airports for 21 years I'm a
January 6th defendant can we say that
and I wrote a phone call we're ready if
I'd have a copy I'll give to you that
sounds great you look fantastic what
prompted the outfit I started this after
the election was stolen I actually by
the way so the the woman is dressed with
I can't even describe it she seems to
have like a tentacle wig of red white
and blue and then like a crazy glitter
hat and it's just it's an insane outfit
and it's funny because it's like what
what made you start dressing like this
well when they stole the election from
Trump I started dressing like a lunatic
oh that makes sense a Halloween costume
and I was in Arizona doing a patriot
party out there and my costume was in
Abilene Texas so I was like I need to
find a reason to wear it so the first
time I wore it was November of 2021 and
I'm back at car rally and then it just
became a thing and now I wear it to all
the events well it is great you look
fantastic it's energizing I think people
are excited I'm gonna bring it over here
to Brian who's got announcements yeah
they're gonna try to get it looked like
Christina Bob actually got a signal from
someone off camera to get away from that
and then this is the last this is really
really funny
you know how it's a very it's like a
point of Pride at some of these rallies
to say you came from really far away it
really just proves your cultist
credentials but they love to say oh I
drove five hours ten hours whatever a
woman explains she drove five hours to
the Trump rally and the interviewer
tries to push on her that the gas prices
were probably crazy and the woman admits
you know their gas prices really weren't
that bad
it's not too bad but I'm sure the gas
prices were bad well uh
you know wasn't too bad
for what a year and a half there's
they've been saying Joe Biden's gas
prices are destroying the country and
this woman goes you know we've came from
five hours away really we didn't really
pay that much gas prices were actually
quite reasonable every little detail of
this cult is putting SNL out of business
I mean you can't really parody this and
then the last component of this the last
component of this yes is Mike pillow
let's go to that next my pillow CEO and
founder Mike Lindell known to us as
pillow the guy who wants to sue the
machines we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines he spoke
outside the Trump rally in Ohio remember
his phone was recently seized by the FBI
at a Hardee's drive-through pillow is
potentially in very serious trouble
legally we looked at the search warrant
last week
um he spoke for almost 90 straight
minutes outside the Trump rally and his
brain is mush his brain is mush check
this out I was in Georgia on
January 4th of 2021 and I was down there
at that big rally for the two Center
runoffs right and I said I all of a
sudden I started praying and I go God
please let them take both of these
senators and you're going okay Mike you
did it no Okay the reason I say that I'm
a marketer and I'm going if I was if I
was working for that evil I would say
give them back one of these Senators so
they shut up about the election
okay now they've done that maybe not you
guys but most the people in this country
would have said my birthday guys we
still understand that we got we'll get
them back in 2022. okay any idea what
he's talking about anybody well I got
news for you there wouldn't have been a
2022
it were when they stole them both
right and everyone's going now what are
we gonna do maybe there was election
crime you know people that were on The
Fringe are all going you know 100
million people in country when now what
yeah so not making a lot of sense is
Mike pillow and then last clip here as
you might remember again it was the FBI
who executed the search warrant on
pillow took his phone and so on and so
forth now he says he will be suing the
FBI for the violation of basically the
entire Bill of Rights listen to this
okay
my lawyers and I got
we got together over a Hardee's I
couldn't tell you what they have over a
Hardy's uh you know chicken sandwich I
guess and on Tuesday we're still in the
United States government and the FBI
we're showing up for violating a First
Amendment race our fourth amendment
rights are simply never rights
the more amendments he mentions the more
the crowd cheers the lawsuit
um really amazing I mean truly truly
incredible stuff and this guy's in
serious trouble he really is I mean and
we you know we like to joke about pillow
and he was recently all over our
Facebook page leaving all sorts of
comments arguing with many of you as
some of you noticed it's all fun and
games until the FBI takes your phone and
Mike pillow could be in serious trouble
and remember he would be much better off
if he had just stuck to selling pillows
and slippers and straight jackets or
whatever he sells uh he would be better
off Trump would have been better off if
he never got involved in any of this
stuff and now it's going to be years of
problems for them but there it is a
complete House of Horrors Sideshow
outside and before the Trump rally but
the scariest moment probably the Trump
rally itself those incredibly cult-like
moments with his fans holding up one
finger and if you know what that was
about let me know we're still trying to
figure it out crazy crazy times in the
United States of America
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright so
as we continue to in some sense wait to
see what ultimately happens with
criminal charges against the failed
former president Donald Trump he has
returned to his Mar-A-Lago home for the
first time since the now Infamous search
warrant that was served the raid as many
call it in Mar-A-Lago and Donald Trump
is absolutely Furious he's raging that
the FBI allegedly didn't take their
shoes off when they went into his house
and all sorts of other crazy things
there's just a lot going on in some of
the cultists were up all night waiting
to welcome Donald Trump trumpet
Mar-A-Lago so let's go through all of it
a Business Insider reports Donald Trump
is back at Mar-A-Lago and raging about
FBI agents not taking off their shoes
while searching his bedroom Donald Trump
published a message to truth social also
known as Troth Central where he said
quote
arrived in Florida last night and had a
long and detailed chance to check out
the scene of yet another government
crime the FBI's raid and break-in of my
home Mar-A-Lago remember it was not a
crime and it was not a break-in the FBI
showed up with a search warrant uh FBI
director signed off on it attorney
general signed off on it a judge signed
off on it perfectly legal Trump going on
to say I guess they don't think there is
a fourth amendment anymore and to them
there isn't of course there is no Fourth
Amendment violation because of the
things I just mentioned Trump continuing
in any event after what they have done
the place will never be the same it was
quote ransacked now why does Trump put
ransacked in quotes does he mean it
wasn't really ransacked
because when you put it in quotes it
almost suggests he doesn't think it was
ransacked anyway and in Far different
condition than the way I left it many
agents and they didn't even take off
their shoes in my bedroom
nice nice now to give you a sense of the
level of cultishness that's going on
here
there were people waiting for Trump's
arrival
in the middle of the night
lining the street check this out
coming back to his Florida
Home Boulevard we
have Flags
yeah this is a cult
this is a cult and we it's not even like
I'm necessarily passing a value judgment
I mean I do in other segments obviously
I think it's an absurd cult based on
lies and confusion but
it's it's a cult and if you we've spoken
to cult experts and that is indeed what
it is there's another video this one is
from
um this one was from yesterday afternoon
which was hours before Trump even got
back
real America's voice American Sunrise
was there this was at 8 A.M and you see
all these people holding crosses some
guy dressed as Trump American flags
Trump Flags other paraphernalia a sign
that said Trump won hunk for Trump
um just all sorts of different
characters because this you know they're
waiting to welcome a potential criminal
that's what they're doing here now my
prediction is
that with Donald Trump back at
Mar-A-Lago
and understand there's two parts to this
one Trump's back at Mar-A-Lago which he
considers the scene of the crime or
whatever I think it'll be it'll trigger
him more than being in New York
um being back there and that will
probably lead to a particularly unhinged
Trump but also Mar-A-Lago has become a
sort of like uh it's almost like the
wedding at the beginning of the
Godfather where all of the acolytes and
brown nosers and suck ups are making
their pilgrimages so to speak and that's
what they do at Mar-A-Lago Trump hosts
people everything everybody from you
know Kyle Rittenhouse to other
right-wing Heroes yeah I know and so
it's likely I would say that Trump's
visitors are going to fire him up and
give him ideas he'll probably be meeting
with lawyers and so I expect it's going
to be a really really crazy week
um one other little note on what's been
going on with Trump lately there has
been a preview released by Newsmax of
what they're calling a special and this
is a special in which right-wing actor
John Voigt who's the father of actress
Angelina Jolie
um John Voight who really has not seemed
with it for a while in terms of his
connection to reality he actually wept
during the interview or maybe wept is
too much he cried so this is something
else we're going to be watching out for
very very closely and she came in and
you said here you have a little bit of
and she said well I have some cancer
issues
and
see I'm getting emotional see this is
from the YouTube you keep saying the
champ because you can't watch The Champ
without crying well I can't I can't just
go through this story without crying
and you said I'll take care yeah
so uh a visibly emotional Jon Voight
overcome with how
good of a person and genuine and caring
and all of these other things that we
have no evidence for uh Donald Trump is
so that's the latest there and we'll
keep an eye on Mar-A-Lago this week
could be could be quite a week the new
thing
seems to be fat shaming people who have
abandoned the Trump cult
last week I played a video for you which
we'll review later of Donald Trump going
after William Barr who is still a
right-wing nut I mean William Barr is
still a right-wing nut but William Barr
has said
um you know these this classified
document stuff is crazy and Trump didn't
win the election yeah Will William Barr
has stated some factual things uh Trump
said all he wanted to do is eat so the
next one is that now Trump is fat
shaming Chris Christie now Chris
Christie is obese that's absolutely true
but so is Donald Trump and so there's a
couple different factors to this and
we're going to talk about that in a
moment
um Donald Trump this is Yahoo news uh
actually a Business Insider it seems
Donald Trump shares fat shaming photo of
Chris Christie on Truth social following
critical Mar-A-Lago interview
Donald Trump shared a photo on Truth
social of a large man leaning over a
buffet counter he captioned the post
Chris Christie at a Roy Rogers at 11 PM
in the evening trying to console himself
Trump has been accused of fat shaming
Christy after Christy gave a critical
ABC news interview
now we don't know who the man in the
picture is take a look at this picture
just so if you're watching
it really does look like Chris Christie
and I've been in a room this is so it
sounds like I'm I'm
joking but I've been in a room that had
a food
station with Chris Christie when we were
both at politicon and behind the scenes
they had a whole food thing for us
it does look like Chris Christie I mean
I don't know whether it's Chris Christie
or not but Donald Trump posting Chris
Christie at a Roy Rogers at 11 p.m in
the evening trying to console himself uh
and of course he is just attacking Chris
Christie for being obese here is the
clip I mentioned of him going after
William Barr because Barr is overweight
[Music]
ships that we have these weak stupid
people
it's attorney generals that don't know
how to do their job like Bill Barr all
we want to do is
all he wanted to do was eat so there's a
couple things here number one the
criticisms of the people that have
abandoned Trump have to be like this
because even though there's still people
I don't agree with you know John Bolton
William Barr Chris Christie and some of
them haven't even really abandoned Trump
some of them have just said I like Trump
but he's wrong about this one thing
their criticisms of trump are completely
substantive in almost all cases and so
it's not like Trump can come back at
them with anything substantive because
he would just be lying which he has no
problem doing but it would sort of be
very obvious so instead he has to go to
this type of stuff oh he's fat he's
having this this different type of thing
that's one part of it that he's focusing
on this because there's really no
substantive response to the things that
these folks are saying the other part of
it is that Trump is obese
and so Trump making fun or attacking
others because they are overweight is
also weird and and you know I I don't
know that I need to give you these
numbers necessarily but just to kind of
like check my math
Trump claims to be six foot three and
two thirty nine now that would put him
like us right on the edge of being obese
according to BMI now BMI is not a
perfect metric we know that if you're a
bodybuilder
a BMI will say you're obese and that's
not relevant or accurate in any kind of
operational sense but for a lot of
people it gives us kind of an idea now I
don't believe Trump 6-3 and I don't
believe Trump is 239 and most people
don't we know Trump's not six three
because Barack Obama is six two and Tom
Brady is 6'4 and when Trump's next to
Brady even wearing what we it's pretty
widely known Trump wears lifts wearing
whatever shoes Trump wears he's notably
shorter than Tom Brady notice so he's
nowhere near six three Brady six four
and he seems to be about the same height
or slightly shorter than Barack Obama so
when you know that and you say well
Trump is conservative Trump has to weigh
at least 255. he might weigh 265. if
Trump is six two or six one and weighs
255 or 265 it's all obese it's all
obesity so do I care that Trump's obese
no Trump doesn't exercise and eats a
terrible diet it's kind of not shocking
but he's going after people a lot
because they are obese or overweight
when he himself is of course as well so
this is another you know what are the
principles that we continue to see
um Republicans claim to have one set of
principles and abandon them when it's
inconvenient
uh Trump uh Trump and other Republicans
they love to make allegations which we
later learn were actually almost like
confessions of the things they were
doing or the things that they planned to
do themselves voter fraud uh trying to
steal an election they didn't win is of
course at the top of the list and um
also
uh claiming that they are about policy
and substance and whatever else and then
fat shaming their political opponents
when they can't come up with anything
substantive to say so their principles
actually don't matter they only care
about their principles when they are
convenient we have a voicemail number
and that number is 2192 David P uh this
some of you might like this the San
Antonio troll has come out of the
woodwork and he is once again slamming
me for things I never said and that I
don't believe we have been hearing from
the San Antonio troll for years and one
of the Hallmarks of the calls to our
voicemail number from the San Antonio
troll is that he will slam me and
criticize me for things that he must
have either made up altogether
uh or heard on a different show because
they don't reflect in any way things
that I've said on this program this is
an exact uh example of that here the San
Antonio troll slams me for the things I
said and the things I believe about the
Ron DeSantis Martha's Vineyard stun
um he's just confused and for those of
you who listen to other Progressive
shows
let me know if you can tell who he might
actually be talking about
Pac-Man it is the uh uh your dear old
friend Santa troll yeah um I'm from
Texas and I saw you flip out about this
story where oh my God
wasn't this show I wasn't flipping out
at all
um
I think it's funny you're flipping out
and getting kind of a little triggered
and it's funny that they be you know the
great Rich wealthy people of masa's
Vineyard already deported these people
so it it's not a deportation when you go
to a different state first of all and
secondly as I've talked about earlier
Martha's Vineyard is a tiny island with
very few jobs and even fewer jobs off
season there's a few hotels and you know
a couple stop and shops there there's
very little to do so there's just no
jobs there for the Immigrant I mean this
whole concept of deportation is crazy
um and you and by the way
the last before today and this voicemail
was left over the weekend
I hadn't even talked about the
immigrants leaving Martha's Vineyard so
this couldn't possibly be about anything
I said but you've always been in favor
of old reporters
there all of a sudden
not not this show as many of you know I
have never been in favor of open borders
as I have said before we need a path to
citizenship for those who came here as
minors and are still here and this is
really their home we need immigration
reform the wall is pretty dumb I have
never been for open borders in fact
there are people in my audience to my
left who do want open borders and I've
said no countries are allowed to have a
border and to enforce it but let's do it
in a way that makes sense
this proves my point of liberalism you
to everything is the moral High ground
with you you are the you're more than oh
we should let everybody in we should
give this to everybody that's never been
something I've said do this nobody
should carry around guns it's very easy
to take these holier than thou
Physicians
when you live 2 000 miles away yeah not
positions I've taken but talk to
somebody who maybe has taken them it's
all Pac-Man two thousand miles away in
your big double-gated Community with
armed security guards in front at the
ready it's very easy to say hey let
everybody into our borders yep okay so
anyway I've never said let everybody in
very very confused individual my here's
my request
I am more than in it's not I'm willing
I'm interested in receiving critiques of
My Views being corrected I issue
Corrections all of that
but call in and talk to me about
something I've said that's my that's my
request all right we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
they're going to find themselves as bad
all of Puerto Rico is without
electricity as hurricane Fiona has made
landfall I hope
that Joe Biden's response to this
hurricane is going to be better than
that of Donald Trump during Trump's term
we're going to talk about it we are
going to talk about the special Master
assigned to review the documents taken
from Trump's Mar-A-Lago his name is
Raymond Deary we'll tell you all about
him and we are also going to talk about
Gavin Newsom the governor of California
challenging Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis to a debate after migrants were
sent to Massachusetts as we have
extensively covered all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show don't
miss it sign up at jointpackman.com and
I'll see you then
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors real quick go
check out jayatel the UK's most exciting
electronic music duo their newest
release connected is available wherever
you get music it's energetic melodic
blast of Electronica ingeniously infused
with acoustic instruments and they
support the David Pacman show check them
out using the link below